this is what people do let's take a look
at this uh hokey pokey video
you want to talk about
ev the news right now by the way
is there anything more disturbing than
the news trying to do feel good stories
like i am one of these people that go
the news is too negative
but then you go outside
and you you realize
that it's kind of accurate it doesn't
mean their targets are you know always
valid or but there's a lot of [ __ ] up
[ __ ] happening
so
now here's how i measure how much [ __ ]
up [ __ ] is happening not even the
negative stories which we all know
already or the um panic you know the
news is always in a panic about
everything
it is what is crazier than the negative
choice is the feel good stories
have gotten
so
bad and so insane
that you genuinely
because this is all they got
this is all they have to take your mind
off the plague and the impending
economic collapse the eviction
moratorium people living in their cars
violence in the street gun to your head
at lunch we'll show you that video later
people eating lunch on the street gun in
your head armed robbery take your money
riots corrupt uh
politicians corrupt police everything in
order to take your mind off that they go
to the feel good uh stories and the bag
of stories that they pick are so
disturbing
in in fact they're actually more
disturbing
than the hell that we're all used to by
now we're all used to the hell by now 27
years old healthy coven dead
in an hour
i mean that's all the stories they do
about kova they're like he was a
personal trainer and he ran up the
mountain every day he rescued dogs and
he had a beautiful wife and child and
now he's dead
coved and you're like [ __ ] and you look
at the guy he's ripped he's on like a
mountain he's got a beautiful wife he's
got three kids and a dog it looks
weirdly photoshopped i'm like does he
exist is this real but who knows and it
probably is but you know we we're all
used to that right now we're all used to
that horrible like
auto fatalities we're all used to like
you know
street racing like someone just sitting
in a light and then these two demon
children
street racing just kill that person and
that person like you know it'll it'll be
like she was waiting to make a left into
the you know parking lot of a walgreens
and two street racers killed her and her
baby
and so you're used to that you're like
[ __ ] but you're used to it it makes
sense you go ya
ya
that's that
random acts of violence we get it
you know
waffle house brawls we we
but the feel good stories
have become so insane
and disconnected from reality
that they are now more troubling you
find yourself staring at them and the
news doesn't even know how to do a
positive story anymore
first of all they all almost
they all the feel-good stories involve
people dying or about to die
just to give you an idea of
the feel-good stories they involve
terminal disease or the elderly
those are the that's the feel-good hour
that's the happy
minute at the end like a make-a-wish kid
something like that something like that
or or you know we all know the one where
it's like he walked 30 miles every day
to work
and everybody bought him a saturn
we got everyone in his job to donate you
know 50 and we bought him a used saturn
that when it breaks down he can't even
get parts for because they don't make
saturns anymore he'll be walking again
in no time but put it and let's make it
go viral on facebook because it's still
a great country where we care about our
workers happy labor day we all know that
story right like this person had no
shoes they'd be like this person had no
shoes and instead of going why do they
not have shoes right or they they work
every day why do they not have a car
you're supposed to go well all's well
that ends well he got a [ __ ]
1998 saturn
and he'll be thrilled now
um
but play this
feel-good story because this is about
uh i'm not even gonna tell you what it's
about let's just enjoy this together
i'll periodically stop it to try to
explain to you what's going on because
i've watched it several times this is
the good people at where cbs i think
this is cbs evening these are the good
people at the cbs evening news trying to
take your mind off all of the other
horrors with this piece of fun and light
which by the way this is heavier than
anything i've ever seen
[Music]
opinions vary when it comes to music one
person hears a symphony another person
hears noise but cbs's steve hartman
discovered a song that can get a whole
neighborhood dancing here's tonight's on
the road
on the road so ready dan already you
know it's rough
on the road never means anything good
right
on tonight's on the road that means like
we're really out there that's cbs's way
of saying we are out there
in the sticks
this is how much contempt they have for
people that don't live in like l.a or
new york
they're like on the road and by on the
road we mean
somewhere in hell
we're broadcasting somewhere in hell on
the road you know where people are just
eating each other's corpses we've sent
one of our reporters out there to bring
you a story that is completely insane
dancing days are done phyllis
brinkerhoff of prairie village kansas
says she's not too old to appreciate a
sick beat
in fact mrs b as she's known in the
neighborhood is obsessed with one dance
song in particular it's just a fun
joyous song you put your right arm in
the hokey pokey
you know how when you love a song you
want your friends to love it too
well that's why mrs b gave her neighbor
melanie mendry's a hokey pokey cd and
started talking about the song
so this is in kansas it's an old one i
can see her name pop up i was obsessed
with the whole and i just thought oh
and it is
it's probably like a member
of the fred phelps church
like this woman they're probably
conveniently leaving out that like she
protested like marine funerals
with the god hates [ __ ] sign on oak tag
for the majority of her life in kansas
but now but listen to this she's
obsessed with the hokey pokey so this is
the feel-good story of cbs they found a
woman
who is
mentally ill
and obsessed with a very annoying
song for children
the hokey pokey
she can't get enough of it
she's insane
they found an insane woman
who's obsessed with the hokey pokey
continue this it's the hokey pokey
hi this is phyllis mrs b left dozens of
messages
i really do need to talk to you urgently
pleading her case
cd i gave you are you hooked on it yet
and i just would always say not quite
yet
melanie's respect this woman
this old bat
gives this neighbor a cd of the hokey
pokey and then harasses her
and keeps calling her and goes are you
hooked on the hokey pokey yet
this is a story
that's supposed to make you feel good
about the direction
of the country this old bat
gives this woman a hokey pokey cd
she's like an mk ultra victim or
something this is a crazy behavior it's
crazy behavior
and then she calls this woman repeatedly
harassing her and her child going are
you hooked on it yet are you
listening are you listening
i mean this is like the behavior of
sirhan surhan
who was activated to kill bobby kennedy
probably by the hokey pokey they started
playing that he blacked out and then he
came too in the kitchen of the
ambassador hotel standing over a corpse
me and ray were laughing so hard they're
like ethel kenny what are the older
kennedys i forget maybe not ethel
somebody wrote a letter to keep sarah
hansen in prison that's all the kennedys
have left now he's trying to keep this
old [ __ ] prison this old patsy that's
all they have left trying to keep this
old patsy in jail
let's continue this feel-good bit
baffled mrs b
you know most people don't care really
at all for the hokey pokey really
really
i find that very amazing do you
still she knew her crusade was all but
lost
then one day mrs b happened to mention
that her birthday was coming up her 93rd
and when melanie heard that she decided
to embrace what she'd been resisting
or to put it in hokey pokey parlance
she put her whole self in
we made copies of the invitation we
rolled them in little scrolls and we
wrapped ribbons around them and traipsed
up and down the street you put your
whole self and now they have the fattest
they have more videos
this is the feel good story about
america
by the way they went through the
neighborhood in kansas
they have all these people who can't see
their feet
on the lawn and they they all can't do
the hokey pokey
they can't even do a child's dance
these are the citizens of america
and they've all come to dance for this
old witch
she's doing some black magic ceremony uh
in her front yard and these tubs of lard
can't even get the hokey pokey right
and this is and just finish this but
again this is supposed to make you feel
like we're on the right track and are
you know things aren't that bad you got
an antifa member far left here can you
see that blue hair the blue haired
little girl
no i don't oh yeah yeah it's a blue hair
the blue haired girl in kansas they get
while you they get wild over there let's
see the rest of this
the smile on her face was so big
it doesn't take that much
to make someone's day
and i think we could all do a little
more of it shut up because look at this
what's next retired flight attendant
honors colleagues killed on 9 11.
these are the good stories this is the
fun this is cbs retired flight attendant
honors people killed on 9 11.
that's 30 seconds yeah third they've
devoted 30 seconds to this that's 30 too
much
can we play this can we yeah
well tonight a retired flight attendant
is on a mission to honor the flight
crews killed in the september 11th
attacks
paulie veneto is walking more than 200
miles from boston where united flight
175 took off from on the morning of the
attacks to one world trade center and
he's pushing a beverage cart along his
three-week journey
holly actually knew some of the crew
members who were killed and he wanted to
honor them
to raise money for the families of 9 11
victims
thank you paulie
yeah that's good thank you paulie good
luck
well there's that that's a feel-good
story that's
happening